hi sisters James Charles here and
welcome back to my youtube channel oh my
gosh it feels so weird to be sitting
here in the studio on camera recording
this video for you guys but I am so
beyond excited because it is about time
James Charles is back on YouTube just
one month after his dramatic fallout
with Tati Westbrook I'm so disappointed
in myself
the twenty-year-old makeup artist made a
colorful come back on Tuesday posting
his first makeup tutorial in over a
month which included this special
announcement
I do wanna do something special for
Pride Month all proceeds from this video
ends in May the Beauty Expert announced
that he would be taking a break from
YouTube in a video titled no more lies I
decided that I'm going to be taking some
much-needed time away from content
corruption it all stems from the tension
between James and his former friend and
mentor Tati Westbrook who broke the
internet when she posted a forty three
minute long confessional titled bye
sister denouncing James's character as a
result he lost nearly two million
subscribers in two days this ego is so
big that he will think that everything
is about him Tati explained why she was
cutting ties with her former sister
accusing him of betraying her and
criticizing his behavior when the
cameras weren't rolling it's gonna be
like the downfall of your career don't
do it James has kept a low profile for
the past month after putting that drama
to rest when I said that I was taking
your social media break I've had it is
that from like being so in it but has
been slowly making his way back out on
the scene including attending Kylie
Jenner's launch of Kylie skins
[Music]
I'm just handling it day by day and
trying my absolute best and of course
learning from my mistakes and it's a
learning process there's no guidebook on
how to do this it's just be yourself and
hopefully people are there for the ride
[Music]